[Music]
it's
it's impossible his concentration was so
great
that he didn't know he had spoken aloud
he closed one eye entirely
then opened it slowly hoping against
hope he then worked his tongue into a
corner of his cheek and rotated it about
he watched stared a pulse was drumming
fiercely in his forehead
as he backed away from the mirror he had
first noticed it a short time ago
seven days to be exact it is logical to
suppose that he would have known of it
sooner
if he had been a vaynerman most
certainly then
he would have looked into mirrors a
great deal oftener
but jay swartz was a mild man a meek man
a man completely devoid of ego he wore
his habits the way he wore his clothes
soberly he did not sin he would not
he did not cheat he could not three
drinks before dinner
and his reactions unmistakably informed
him that he'd had enough
he was like that once again he shot a
covert glance at the mirror
there it was plain to see
jay swartz had been brought up properly
but that is an expression that has lost
its true meaning
to speak with exactitude it is better to
say that he had been brought up
primly in an era where modesty was
considerably more than a fetish
an era where the most innocuous words
called down condemnation
upon the luckless user j schwartz's
family proudly outdid themselves
in righteous self-effacement completely
cloaked with the mantle of selflessness
or so they insisted they balance
themselves with practice step upon the
tightrope of virtue
no matter the season their bodies were
swathed in layer upon layer of raiment
indoors their comportment was such as to
assure them
front row seats in the heavenly
orchestra of harpists
or so they insisted jay had never been
one to rebel
he was the sort born to accept orders
unquestioningly
if even in the privacy of one's room it
was immodest and
wrong to undress before dousing the
lights
he carefully put out the lights before
removing his breeches
his parents had instructed him he obeyed
them
if he had to go to the lavatory it would
never do to say so
that would have been grievously shocking
any simple excuse to leave the room was
acceptable under those conditions
but never the immodest truth but all
these bugaboos
paled before the one strict immutable
rule that pervaded the swartz household
serving the interests of virtue one
might do everything in one's power
and then fail how by looking
smiling at daring to admire one's
reflected form
in a mirror the human form was a debased
thing of evil
that only served to lead its owner off
the garden path
thus logically it was a thing to remain
unseen
avoided jay's father used it for shaving
that was its purpose one of jay's most
memorable recollections
was the time that he had been caught
he'd lost a tooth as boy's will and was
entirely engrossed in exploring the
bloody cavity with an inquisitive finger
the mirror helped a great deal as he
probed and poked
until jay
he swerved nearly upsetting himself and
paled
yes father ungodly brat you were
lasciviously admiring yourself
i i don't understand father
do not trifle with me i have explained
the sin often enough
it was the big word i didn't understand
and honest i was just fooling
which is as far as jay got his gasp was
cut off
as a gnarled hand jerked at the back of
his collar
the shaving strop was seized raised
aloft
then brought down with a singing swish
jay's cry of pain suffered the same
brief span that his gasp had lasted
the steadily flailing strip of leather
effectively stifled everything but an
agonized wish for death
again and again it rose and fell the
regularity was monotonous
the pain eventually indescribable
things after a while resolved into a
whirling world of unrelieved torture
again and again rose the leather flail
down and down it beat
against the semi-conscious jerking form
that was j
schwartz jay finally fainted
graphic experience is forever etched
upon the consciousness of a child
jay never forgot that beating it had the
constant impact of a sledgehammer
swung against a huge brazen gong the
reverberations went on
and on jay grew older and finally left
home to establish his own way in the
world
he trod in minor paths luckier than most
men
he never was troubled by an
all-consuming ambition
the highways for others the byway is for
him
a small job a small room these quite
comfortably fitted his small desires
his position with a large insurance
company was safe and steady
nobody resents a man who doesn't covet
positions that aren't better than his
nobody wields an economic knife against
a man who is supremely satisfied to
trudge a tuneless treadmill
he was accepted with the same careless
complacence that is usually associated
with a slightly worn piece of office
furniture
and he was considered very much as
devoid of personality or hidden depth
but they would have all been surprised
he did have a secret
jay swartz was still afraid of mirrors
psychologically conditioned by the
ultra-stern conditions of his youth
his fear never diminished to the
contrary it fed upon itself
and grew constantly morbidly
a man incapable of making living enemies
he found himself in the anomalous
position
of having an inanimate foe he used
mirrors as sparingly as was humanly
possible
brushing his teeth and washing his face
were easy
no ordeal there but shaving was a
shuddering time of terror that had to be
agonized through
every morning and now
it's impossible but it was possible
it was there plain to see plain to see
even as his eyes clung to the mirror and
his mouth was drawn thin with horror
his reflection was laughing at him
his hand stole to his face his reflected
hand
didn't there were new lines in his face
but his mirrored face was full and
untroubled
his eyelids twitched uncontrollably but
not so in the likeness that was flung
back at him
horribly silently the face in the mirror
kept laughing and laughing
it had been a week ago that he had first
noticed a week ago that his reflection
had rebelled
a week ago that his mirrored personality
had begun defying him
it might have begun sooner he hadn't
noticed
until until one morning it had winked
obscenely at him
and ever since he remembered now
the ancient germanic legend of the man
who had met his double
it had been wringing its hands death
he fought himself but his eyes shot
toward his reflection
it was grinning bringing its hands
the psychiatrist wielded his pen with
sure broad strokes
a man untroubled by personal ghosts a
man who slew the morbid fancies and
terrorizing thoughts of others
he scratched a last notation his lips
forming the inaudible words
psychosis auto-suggestion
jay squirmed forward in his chair as the
psychiatrist leaned back and studied him
does does it mean i'm crazy
the other's full rich carefully
practiced tones fell upon jay swartz
like a protective benediction
no absolutely not you were as sane as
well as i am this last accompanied by a
resonant chuckle
then the thing i see can't hurt me it is
impossible for it to hurt you
impossible because you do not see it
but doctor please a moment
well-manicured fingers interlace
themselves across a well-padded stomach
from what you have told me you are a man
pursued by phantoms
it is not your fault mr swartz you have
related how your boyhood was completely
dominated by a thorough abnegation of
healthy emotion
no outlets no outlets at all well sir
what is the result what
as you grew older mr swartz you cast off
the narrow outlook with which you were
most effectively swaddled
you didn't know it but you did and
due to the inexorable law of nature you
began to think for yourself
that of course brought its uh problems
i don't understand let us put it this
way
a man who has been perishing of thirst
will not allow logic to stand in his way
when he is confronted with plenteous
water he will drink and drink
until he is uncomfortably sated if
undeterred
he will become rather sick you mr swartz
are that thirsty man i see
exactly you had a thirst for normalcy
it was during your childhood
consistently denied to you
you left home and found yourself with an
all-consuming thirst for being a healthy
ego
for being natural you follow me
it wasn't a question but j schwartz felt
constrained to answer
yes it was getting so clear now
so normally explainable that he had to
show his improvement by joining in
and approving of the logical explanation
well sir you overdid yourself the abrupt
change to a normal way of living and
acting stirred up half forgotten vistas
of your unfortunate youth
subconsciously that is once again you
are being threatened with
unfair punishment inwardly of course you
probably never even perceived
suspected the first sign was the product
of an overworked
though to you unsuspected imagination
the fear complex the worry over being
hideously punished
as you told me you were because you were
doing something that is unalterably
natural
but doctor my remaining fear of mirrors
you are not afraid i
mr schwartz believe me you only think
you are afraid
that is why you've been avoiding mirrors
with such careful conscientiousness
these past few years
as the snake struggles to shed its skin
so you are struggling
and forgive the comparison as the
reptile finally emerges in new shining
armor
so you are emerging then what shall i do
face your phantom mr swartz defy it
gaze into your mirror steadily without
fear
your clouded imagination will be cleared
by the calm cooling breezes of reason
look into my mirror
steadily precisely drive out the false
visions that have been plaguing you so
unfairly
once gone they will never return on that
i stake my reputation
it was a new jay swartz who turned the
key of his small apartment
it was a new jay schwartz who tossed his
coat onto the bed
it was something he had wanted to do all
his life a life given to circumspectly
genuflecting
to all the hallowed proprieties that was
over
done he was a snake shedding its dull
skin for a brighter one
a butterfly emerging in innocent glory
from its dull chrysalis
a man he turned toward the bathroom
he couldn't help the feeling of aversion
of fear
but wasn't he now a man he was
incontestably hand upon the door
fear twist the knob
no think psychiatrists advice a learned
man
helps people who need guidance twist the
knob
try sweat forming on a corrugated
forehead
twist the knob everything explained
logically
exactly mathematically truthfully that
last very important
twist the knob and he was inside
walk up to the mirror boldly stare
steadily
unafraid block out the false phantoms
do it it's easy one leg before the other
go ahead hesitation only hurts makes
things harder
foolish nothing to be worried about all
carefully explained
habits of a lifetime lurking unfair
no substance all explained figments
palpably worthy of derision go ahead
and he was before the mirror open your
eyes
stare steadily open your eyes nothing
can hurt you
it will help teach you the truth help
you
open broad lanes to happiness wipe out
the past
the gray past the punishing past open
your eyes
see the new world your world open your
eyes
and he opened his eyes his reflection
nothing to worry about it looked at him
and he looked at it
calm both calm as it should be
expressions the same
as they should be psychiatrists write as
he should be
learned man wise man helpful man
good advice best advice go ahead
stare at it staring pride
strength new feeling of of
no can't be impossible
psychiatrist said so learned man wise
man
look again no reflection
laughing silently utterly impossible
wise man said so wealth of experience
can't be wrong
good advice best advice heed it heed it
stare at reflection glare at reflection
don't give up
must win must win don't give up
stare and he screamed
and he screamed he caught himself
lurched out of the bathroom this was no
time to give way to disordered mental
stabs more than evident that his ancient
enemy was weakening
employing last hopeless trickery this
was triumph
triumph get a bit of help nothing
shameful about using all the means at
one's disposal to rid oneself of a dying
enemy nothing to do with one's manliness
the enemy must be destroyed that is the
only important thing
answering the telephone call the
psychiatrist finally arrived
a bit put out because he'd been
disturbed at his meal
but cloaking his irritation and
impatience with the thought of adding a
substantial amount to an already padded
bill
look doctor the mirror what about it
can't you see no you can't
all i see is that you have a reflection
which is as it should be
but it reacts differently that's why i
called you
i don't understand don't you see
it my enemy is still there however i'm
not afraid
it is a figment i know it you told me so
but it is there to be destroyed isn't
that progress
the psychiatrist backing up
professionally polite
words words that have no meaning
professional
backing to the door understanding
understanding
i'm sorry i troubled you sir it was
nothing nothing at all
quite all right mr schwartz just take my
advice
don't be afraid don't be afraid and he
was gone
failure the psychiatrist had lied
he had seen it too wouldn't admit it
have to help oneself the only way
use any means any means
out with logic forswear what is
fallaciously taught
seek that which can really help seek
that which is ridiculed and mocked
but secretly feared seek the strange
powers that all jibe at
because the true answer is there for the
asking
many libraries many many bookstores
laughing faces incredulous faces
sneering faces
he knows he knows they sneer and mock
because they are afraid cannot seek
truth as he does
tirelessly and then then
an old bookshop an old man incredibly
nodding understanding tottering to an
inner room
a book musty ancient refusal of payment
smiling jay swartz entered his apartment
he opened the book and studied he smiled
it was all so easy how much simpler if
he had done this first
he read on there was the diagram to
chalk upon the floor
he drew it there were the multi-syllable
invocations to in tone
he and toned them there were the careful
passes through the air
the repetition of certain odd phrases
the lit
match that must scorch his fingertips
and as it must be the crouching shape
was there
motionless the shape that would rid him
of the rebellious reflection in the
mirror
the shape that would take the horror out
of his life
it would exact a tribute that was to be
expected
jay swartz was happy truly happy
he cast a side long glance at his
mirrored reflection
could it be yes it was already losing
its shape
becoming tenuous transparent wearing a
look that jay knew
knew was one of helpless pleading no
time for mercy too many years of
subjugation
destroy without conscience destroy
the reflection of him was wavering
almost gone
fighting hopelessly going
gone and the crouched figure stirred
itself
slowly unbent looked up for the first
time
jay swartz threw a frantic look at his
mirror
no reflection no reflection at all
blank blank the figure straightened and
stepped over the chalked lines
it was going to exact its tribute jay
swartz knew this
he also knew that he had incarnated his
double
brought it to life it was wringing its
hands
hands which suddenly swooped to jay
swartz's throat
he knew so many things too
come
late
[Music]
january 3rd this affair of white and
witherspoon's accounts
proves to be a gigantic task there are
20 thick ledgers to be examined and
checked
who would be a junior partner however it
is the first big bit of business which
has been left entirely in my hands
i must justify it but it has to be
finished
so that the lawyers may have the result
in time for the trial
johnson said this morning that i should
have to get the last figure out before
the 20th of the month
good lord well have at it
and if human brain and nerve can stand
the strain
i'll win out at the other side it means
office work from ten to five
and then a second sitting from about
eight to one in the morning
there's drama in an accountant's life
when i find myself in the still
early hours while all the world sleeps
hunting through column after column for
those missing figures
which will turn a respected alderman
into a felon
i understand that it is not such a
prosaic profession after all
on monday i came on the first trace of
defulcation
no heavy game hunter ever got a finer
thrill when first he caught sight of the
trail of his quarry
but i look at the 20 ledgers and think
of the jungle through which i have to
follow him
before i get my kill hard work
but rare sport too in a way i saw the
fat
fellow once at a city dinner his red
face glowing above a white napkin
he looked at the little pale man at the
end of the table
he would have been pale too if he could
have seen the task that would be mine
january 6th what perfect nonsense it is
for doctors to prescribe rest
when rest is out of the question asses
they might as well shout to a man who
has a pack of wolves at his heels that
what he wants
is absolute quiet my figures must be out
by a certain date
unless they are so i shall lose the
chance of my lifetime
so how on earth am i to rest i'll take a
week or so after the trial
perhaps i was myself a fool to go to the
doctor at all
but i get nervous and highly strong when
i sit alone at my work at night
it's not a pain only a sort of fullness
of the head with an occasional mist over
the eyes
i thought perhaps some bromide or
chloral or something of the kind might
do me good
but stop work it's absurd to ask such a
thing
it's like a long distance race you feel
queer at first and your heart thumps and
your lungs
pant but if you have only the pluck to
keep on
you get your second wind i'll stick to
my work and wait for my second wind
if it never comes all the same i'll
stick to my work
two ledgers are done and i'm well on in
the third
the rascal has covered his tracks well
but i pick them up for all that
january 9th i had not meant to go to the
doctor again
and yet i've had to straining my nerves
risking a complete breakdown even
endangering my sanity
that's a nice sentence to have fired off
at one
well i'll stay in the strain and i'll
take the risk and so long as i can sit
in my chair and move a pen
i'll follow the old sinner's slot by the
way
i may as well set down here the queer
experience which drove me this second
time to the doctor
i'll keep an exact record of my symptoms
and sensations
because they are interesting in
themselves a curious psychophysiological
study
says the doctor and also because i'm
perfectly certain that when i am through
with them they will all seem blurred and
unreal
like some queer dream between sleeping
and waking
so now while they are fresh i will just
make a note of them
if only as a change of thought after the
endless figures
there's an old silver-framed mirror in
my room
it was given to me by a friend who had a
taste for antiquities
and he as i happen to know picked it up
at a sale
and had no notion of where it came from
it's a large thing
three feet across and two feet high and
it leans at the back of a side table on
my left as i write
the frame is flat about three inches
across
and very old far too old for hallmarks
or other methods of determining its age
the glass part projects with a beveled
edge
and has the magnificent reflecting power
which is only as it seems to me
to be found in very old mirrors there's
a feeling of perspective when you look
into it
such as no modern glass can ever give
the mirror is so situated that as i sit
at the table
i can usually see nothing in it but the
reflection of the red window curtains
but a queer thing happened last night i
had been working for some hours
very much against the grain with
continual bouts of that mistiness of
which i had complained
again and again i had to stop and clear
my eyes
well on one of these occasions i chanced
to look at the mirror
it had the oddest appearance the red
curtains which should have been
reflected in it
were no longer there but the glass
seemed to be clouded and steamy
not on the surface which glittered like
steel
but deep down in the very grain of it
this opacity when i stared hard at it
appeared to slowly rotate this way in
that
until it was a thick white cloud
swirling in heavy wreaths
so real and solid was it and so
reasonable was i
that i remember turning with the idea
that the curtains were on fire
but everything was deadly still in the
room
no sound saved the ticking of the clock
no movement
saved the slow gyration of that strange
woolly cloud
deep in the heart of the old mirror then
as i looked
the mist or smoke or cloud or whatever
one may call it
seemed to coalesce and solidify at two
points quite close together
and i was aware with a thrill of
interest rather than a fear
that these were two eyes looking out
into the room
a vague outline of a head i could see a
woman's by the hair
but this was very shadowy only the eyes
were quite distinct
such eyes dark luminous filled with some
passionate emotion
fury or horror i could not say which
never have i seen eyes which were so
full of intense vivid life
they were not fixed upon me but stared
out into the room
then as i sat erect passed my hand over
my brow
and made a strong conscious effort to
pull myself together
the dim head faded into the general
opacity
and the mirror slowly cleared and there
were the red curtains once again
a skeptic would say no doubt that i had
fallen asleep over my figures
and that my experience was a dream as a
matter of fact i was never more vividly
awake in my life
i was able to argue about it even as i
looked at it
and to tell myself that it was a
subjective impression
a chimera of the nerves begotten by
worry and insomnia
but why this particular shape and who is
the woman
and what is the dreadful emotion which i
read in those wonderful brown eyes
they come between me and my work for the
first time i have done less than the
daily tally which i had marked out
perhaps that is why i've had no abnormal
sensations tonight
tomorrow i must wake up come what may
january 11th all well
and good progress with my work i wind
the net
coil after coil round that bulky body
but the last smile may remain with him
if my own nerves break over it
the mirror would seem to be a sort of
barometer which marks my brain pressure
each night i have observed that it had
clouded before i reached the end of my
task
dr sinclair who is it seems a bit of a
psychologist
was so interested in my account that he
came round this evening to have a look
at the mirror
i had observed that something was
scribbled and crabbed old characters
upon the metal work at the back
he examined this with a lens but could
make nothing of
it sankx pal
was his final reading of it but that did
not bring us any farther
he advised me to put it away into
another room
but after all whatever i may see in it
is by his own account
only a symptom it is in the cause that
the danger lies
the 20 ledgers not the silver mirror
should be packed away
if only i could do it i'm at the eighth
now
so i progress january 13th
perhaps it would have been wiser after
all if i had packed away the mirror
i had an extraordinary experience with
it last night
and yet i find it so interesting so
fascinating
that even now i will keep it in its
place what on earth is the meaning of it
all
i suppose it was about one in the
morning and i was closing my books
preparatory to staggering off to bed
when i saw her there
in front of me the stage of mistiness
and development must have passed
unobserved
and there she was in all her beauty and
passion and distress
as clear-cut as if she were really in
the flesh before me
the figure was small but very distinct
so much so that every feature and every
detail of dress
are stamped in my memory she is seated
on the extreme left of the mirror
a sort of shadowy figure crouches down
beside her i can dimly discern that it
is a man
and then behind them is a cloud in which
i see figures
figures which move it is not a mere
picture upon which i look
it is a scene in life an actual episode
she crouches and quivers the man beside
her cowers down
the vague figures make abrupt movements
and gestures
all my fears were swallowed up in my
interest
it was maddening to see so much and not
to see more
but i can at least describe the woman to
the smallest point
she is very beautiful and quite young
not more than 5 and 20
i should judge her hair is of a very
rich brown
with a warm chestnut shade finding into
gold at the edges
a little flat pointed cap comes to an
angle in front
and is made of lace edged with pearls
the forehead is high too high perhaps
for perfect beauty
but one would not have it otherwise as
it gives a touch of power and strength
to what would otherwise be a softly
feminine face
the brows are most delicately curved
over heavy eyelids
and then come those wonderful eyes so
large
so dark so full of over-mastering
emotion
of rage and horror contending with a
pride of self-control
which holds her from sheer frenzy the
cheeks are
pale the lips white with agony the chin
and throat most exquisitely rounded
the figure sits and leans forward in the
chair straining and rigid
catalytic with horror the dress is black
velvet
a jewel gleams like a flame in the
breast and a golden crucifix smolders in
the shadow of a fold
this is the lady whose image still lives
in the old silver mirror
what dire deed could it be which has
left its impress there
so that now in another age if the spirit
of a man be but worn down to it
he may be conscious of its presence
one other detail on the left side of the
skirt of the black dress was
as i thought at first a shapeless bunch
of white ribbon
then as i looked more intently or as the
vision defined itself more clearly
i perceived what it was it was the hand
of a man
clenched and nodded in agony which held
on with a convulsive grasp to the fold
of the dress
the rest of the crouching figure was a
mere vague outline
but that strenuous hand shone clear on
the dark background
with a sinister suggestion of tragedy in
its frantic clutch
the man is frightened horribly
frightened
that i can clearly discern what has
terrified him so
why does he grip the woman's dress the
answer lies amongst those moving figures
in the background
they have brought danger both to him and
to her
the interest of the thing fascinated me
i thought no more of its relation to my
own nerves
i stared and stared as if in a theater
but i could get no farther the mist
thinned
there were tumultuous movements in which
all the figures were vaguely concerned
then the mirror was clear once more
the doctor says i must drop work for a
day and i can't afford to do so
for i've made good progress lately it is
quite evident that the visions depend
entirely upon my own nervous state
for i sat in front of the mirror for an
hour tonight with no result whatever
my soothing day has chased them away
i wonder whether i shall ever penetrate
what they all mean
i examined the mirror this evening under
a good light and besides the mysterious
inscription
sank x pal i was able to discern some
signs of heraldic marks
very faintly visible upon the silver
they must be very ancient
as they are almost obliterated so far as
i could make out
they were three spearheads two above and
one below
i will show them to the doctor when he
calls tomorrow
january 14th feel perfectly well again
and i intend that nothing else shall
stop me until my task is finished
the doctor was shown the marks on the
mirror and agreed that they were
armorial bearings
he is deeply interested in all that i
have told him and cross questioned me
closely on the details
it amuses me to notice how he is torn in
two by conflicting desires
the one that his patient should lose his
symptoms the other that the medium
for so he regards me should solve this
mystery of the past
he advised continued rest but did not
oppose me too violently
when i declared that such a thing was
out of the question until the 10
remaining ledgers have been checked
january 17th for three nights i have had
no experiences
my day of rest has borne fruit only a
quarter of my task is left
but i must make a forced march for the
lawyers are clamoring for their material
i will give them enough and some to
spare i have him fast on a hundred
counts
when they realize what a slippery
cunning rascal he is
i should gain some credit from the case
false trading accounts
false balance sheets dividends drawn
from capital
losses written down as profits
suppression of working expenses
manipulation of petty cash it is a fine
record
january 18th headaches
nervous twitches mistiness fullness of
the temples
all the premonitions of trouble and the
trouble came sure enough
and yet my real sorrow is not so much
that the vision should come
as that it should cease before all is
revealed
but i saw more tonight the crouching man
was as visible as the lady whose gown he
clutched
he is a little swarthy fellow with a
black pointed beard
he has a loose gown of damask trimmed
with fur
the prevailing tints of his dress are
red
what a fright the fellow is in to be
sure he cowers and shivers and glares
back over his shoulder
there is a small knife in his other hand
but he is far too tremulous and cowed to
use it
dimly now i begin to see the figures in
the background
fierce faces bearded and dark shape
themselves out of the mist
there is one terrible creature a
skeleton of a man
with hollow cheeks and eyes sunk in his
head
he also has a knife in his hand on the
right of the woman stands a tall man
very young with flax and hair his face
sullen and dour
the beautiful woman looks up at him in
appeal
so does the man on the ground this youth
seems to be the arbiter of their fate
the crouching man draws closer and hides
himself in the woman's skirts
the tall youth bends and tries to drag
her away from him
so much i saw last night before the
mirror cleared
shall i never know what it leads to and
whence it comes
it is not a mere imagination of that i
am very sure
somewhere some time this scene has been
acted
and this old mirror has reflected it but
when
where january 20th
my work draws to a close and it is time
i feel a tenseness within my brain a
sense of intolerable strain
which warns me that something must give
i have worked myself to the limit
but tonight should be the last night
with a supreme effort i should finish
the final ledger
and complete the case before i rise from
my chair
i will do it i will
february 7th i did
my god what an experience i hardly know
if i'm strong enough yet to set it down
let me explain in the first instance
that i am writing this in dr sinclair's
private hospital
some three weeks after the last entry in
my diary
on the night of january 20th my nervous
system finally gave way
and i remembered nothing afterwards
until i found myself
three days ago in this home of rest and
i can rest with a good conscience
my work was done before i went under my
figures are in the solicitor's hands
the hunt is over and now i must describe
that last night
i had sworn to finish my work and so
intently that i stick to it though my
head was bursting
that i would never look up until the
last column had been added
and yet it was fine self-restraint for
all the time i knew that wonderful
things were happening in the mirror
every nerve in my body told me so if i
looked up there was an end of my work
so i did not look up till all was
finished
then when at last with throbbing temples
i threw down my pen
and raised my eyes what a sight was
there
the mirror in its silver frame was like
a stage
brilliantly lit in which a drama was in
progress
there was no mist now the oppression of
my nerves had wrought this amazing
clarity
every feature every movement was as
clear cut as in life
to think that i a tired accountant the
most prosaic of mankind
with the account books of a swindling
bankrupt before me
should be chosen of all the human race
to look upon such a scene
it was the same scene and the same
figures but the drama had advanced a
stage
the tall young man was holding the woman
in his arms
she strained away from him and looked up
at him with loathing in her face
they had torn the crouching man away
from his hold upon the skirt of her
dress
a dozen of them were round him savage
men bearded men
they hacked at him with knives all
seemed to strike him together
their arms rose and fell the blood did
not flow from him
it squirted his red dress was dabbled in
it
he threw himself this way in that purple
upon crimson
like an overripe plum still they hacked
and still the jets shot from him it was
horrible
horrible they dragged him kicking to the
door
the woman looked over her shoulder at
him and her mouth gaped
i heard nothing but i knew that she was
screaming
and then whether it was this
nerve-wracking vision before me
or whether my task finished all the
overwork of the past weeks came in one
crushing weight upon me
the room danced around me the floor
seemed to sink away beneath my feet
and i remembered no more in the early
morning
my landlady found me stretched senseless
before the silver mirror
but i knew nothing myself until three
days ago
when i awoke in the deep peace of the
doctor's nursing home
february 9th only today have i told dr
sinclair my full experience
he had not allowed me to speak of such
matters before
he listened with an absorbed interest
you don't identify this with any
well-known scene in history
he asked with suspicion in his eyes
i assured him that i knew nothing of
history
have you no idea once that mirror came
and to whom it once belonged
he continued have you i
asked for he spoke with meaning
it's incredible said he and yet how else
can one explain it
the scenes which you described before
suggested it
but now it has gone beyond all range of
coincidence
i will bring you some notes in the
evening
later he has just left me
let me set down his words as closely as
i can recall them
he began by laying several musty volumes
upon my bed
these you can consult at your leisure
said he
i have some notes here which you can
confirm
there is not a doubt that what you have
seen is the murder of risio by the
scottish nobles in the presence of mary
which occurred in march 1566
your description of the woman is
accurate the high forehead and heavy
eyelids combined with great beauty
could hardly apply to two women the tall
young man was her husband
darnley rizzio says the chronicle
was dressed in a loose dressing gown of
fur damask
with hoes of russet velvet with one hand
he clutched mary's gown
with the other he held a dagger your
fierce hollow-eyed man
was ruthvan who was new risen from a bed
of sickness
every detail is exact but why to me
i asked and bewilderment why of all the
human race to me
because you were in the fit mental state
to receive the impression
because you chanced to own the mirror
which gave the impression
the mirror you think then that it was
mary's mirror
that it stood in the room where the deed
was done
i am convinced that it was mary's mirror
she had been queen of france
her personal property would be stamped
with the royal arms
what you took to be three spearheads
were really the lilies of france
and the inscription sank x pal
you can expand it to sancte crucis
palatium
someone has made a note upon the mirror
as to whence it came
it was the palace of the holy cross
hollyrood i cried exactly
your mirror came from hollyrood you have
had one very singular experience
and have escaped i trust that you will
never put yourself into the way
of having such another
[Music]
[Music]
unhappy is he to whom the memories of
childhood
bring only fear and sadness wretched is
he
who looks back upon lone hours and vast
and dismal chambers
with brown hangings and maddening rows
of antique books
or upon odd watches and twilight groves
of grotesque
gigantic and vine encumbered trees that
silently waved twisted branches far
aloft
such a lot the gods gave to me to me
the dazed the disappointed the barren
the broken and yet i am strangely
content
and cling desperately to those seer
memories when my mind momentarily
threatens to reach beyond to the other
i know not where i was born saved that
the castle was infinitely old
and infinitely horrible full of dark
passages and having high ceilings
where the eye could find only cobwebs
and shadows
the stones in the crumpling corridor
seemed always hideously damp
and there was an accursed smell
everywhere as of the piled up corpses of
dead generations
it was never light so that i used
sometimes to light candles and gaze
steadily at them for relief
nor was there any sun outdoors since the
terrible trees grew high above the
topmost
accessible tower there was one black
tower which reached above the trees into
the unknown outer sky
but that was partly ruined and could not
be ascended
saved by a well nigh impossible climb up
the sheer wall
stone by stone i must have lived years
in this place
but i cannot measure the time beings
must have cared for my needs
yet i cannot recall any person except
myself
or anything alive but the noiseless rats
and bats and spiders
i think that whoever nursed me must have
been shockingly aged
since my first conception of a living
person was that of somebody mockingly
like myself
yet distorted shriveled and decaying
like the castle
to me there was nothing grotesque in the
bones and skeletons that strewed some of
the stone crypts deep down among the
foundations
i fantastically associated these things
with everyday events
and thought them more natural than the
colored pictures of living beings
which i found in many of the moldy books
from such books i learned all that i
know
no teacher urged or guided me and i do
not recall hearing any human voice in
all those years
not even my own for although i had read
of speech
i had never thought to try to speak
aloud
my aspect was a matter equally unthought
of
for there were no mirrors in the castle
and i merely regarded myself by instinct
as akin to the youthful figures i saw
drawn and painted in the books
i felt conscious of youth because i
remembered so little
outside across the putrid moat and under
the dark mute trees
i would often lie and dream for hours
about what i read in the books
and would longingly picture myself
amidst gay crowds in the sunny world
beyond the endless forests once i tried
to escape from the forest
but as i went farther from the castle
the shade grew denser
and the air more filled with brooding
fear so that i ran frantically back
lest i lose my way in a labyrinth of
knighted silence
so through endless twilights i dreamed
and waited though i knew not what i
waited for
then in the shadowy solitude my longing
for light grew so frantic that i could
rest no more
and i lifted entreating hands to the
single black ruined tower that reached
above the forest and to the unknown
outer sky
and at last i resolved to scale that
tower
fall though i might since it were better
to glimpse the sky
and perish than to live without ever
beholding day
in the dank twilight i climbed the worn
and aged stone stairs
till i reached the level where they
ceased and thereafter clung
perilously to small footholds leading
upward
ghastly and terrible was that dead
stairless cylinder of rock
black ruined and deserted and sinister
with startled bats whose wings made no
noise
but more ghastly and terrible still was
the slowness of my progress for climb as
i might
the darkness overhead grew no thinner
and a new chill as of haunted and
venerable mold assailed me
i shivered as i wondered why i did not
reach the light
and would have looked down had i dared i
fancied that night had come
suddenly upon me and vainly groped with
one free hand for a window embrasure
that i might peer out and above and try
to judge the height i had once attained
all at once after an infinity of awesome
sightless
crawling up that concave and desperate
precipice
i felt my head touch a solid thing and i
knew i must have gained the roof
or at least some kind of floor in the
darkness i raised my free hand
and tested the barrier finding it stone
and immovable
then came a deadly circuit of the tower
clinging to whatever holds the slimy
wall could give
till finally my testing hand found the
barrier yielding
and i turned upward again pushing the
slab or door with my head
as i used both hands in my fearful
ascent
there was no light revealed above and as
my hands went higher
i knew that my climb was for the nonce
ended since the slab was the trap door
of an aperture
leading to a level stone surface of
greater circumference than the lower
tower
no doubt the floor of some lofty and
capacious observation chamber
i crawled through carefully and tried to
prevent the heavy slab from falling back
into place
but failed in the latter attempt as i
lay exhausted on the stone floor
i heard the eerie echoes of its fall
hoped when necessary to pry it up again
believing i was now at prodigious height
far above the accursed branches of the
wood
i dragged myself up from the floor and
fumbled about for windows
that i might look for the first time
upon the sky
and the moon and stars of which i had
read
but on every hand i was disappointed
since all that i found were vast shelves
of marble
bearing odious oblong boxes of
disturbing
size more and more i reflected
and wondered what hoary secrets might
abide in this high apartment
so many eons cut off from the castle
below
then unexpectedly my hands came upon a
doorway
where hung a portal of stone rough with
strange chiseling
trying it i found it locked but with a
supreme burst of strength i overcame all
obstacles
and dragged it open inward as i did so
there came to me the purest ecstasy i
have ever known
for shining tranquilly through an ornate
grating of iron
and down a short stone passageway of
steps that ascended from the newly found
doorway
was the radiant full moon which i had
never before seen
save in dreams and in vague visions i
dared not call memories
fancying now that i had attained the
very pinnacle of the castle
i commenced to rush up the few steps
beyond the door but the sudden veiling
of the moon by a cloud
caused me to stumble and i felt my way
more slowly in the dark
it was still very dark when i reached
the grating which i tried carefully
and found unlocked but which i did not
open for fear of falling from the
amazing height to which i had climbed
then the moon came out most demonic of
all shocks
is that of the abysmally unexpected and
grotesquely unbelievable
nothing i had before undergone could
compare in terror with what i now saw
with the bizarre marvels that sight
implied
the sight itself was as simple as it was
stupefying
for it was merely this instead of a
dizzying prospect of treetops
seen from a lofty eminence they're
stretched around me
on the level through the grating nothing
less than the solid ground
decked and diversified by marble slabs
and columns
and overshadowed by an ancient stone
church whose ruined spire gleamed
spectrally in the moonlight
half unconscious i opened the grating
and staggered out upon the white gravel
path
that stretched away in two directions
my mind stunned and chaotic as it was
still held the frantic craving for light
and not even the fantastic wonder which
had happened
could stay my course i neither knew nor
cared whether my experience was
insanity dreaming or magic but was
determined to gaze on brilliance and
gaiety
at any cost i knew not who i was
or what i was or what my surroundings
might be
though as i continued to stumble along i
became
conscious of a kind of fearsome latent
memory that made my progress
not wholly fortuitous i passed under an
arch out of that region of slabs and
columns
and wandered through the open country
sometimes following the visible road
but sometimes leaving it curiously to
tread across meadows
where only occasional ruins bespoke the
ancient presence of a forgotten road
once i swam across a swift river where
crumbling mossy masonry
told of a bridge long vanished over two
hours must have passed
before i reached what seemed to be my
goal a venerable ivy castle
in a thickly wooded park maddeningly
familiar
yet full of perplexing strangeness to me
i saw that the moat was filled in and
that some of the well-known towers were
demolished
whilst new wings existed to confuse the
beholder
but what i observed with chief interest
and delight
were the open windows gorgeously ablaze
with light
and sending forth sound of the gayest
revelry
advancing to one of these i looked in
and saw an oddly dressed company indeed
making merry and speaking brightly to
one another
i had never seemingly heard human speech
before
and could guess only vaguely what was
said
some of the faces seemed to hold
expressions that brought up incredibly
remote recollections
others were utterly alien i now
stepped through the low window into the
brilliantly lighted room
stepping as i did so from my single
bright moment of hope
to my blackest convulsion of despair and
realization
the nightmare was quick to come for as i
entered
there occurred immediately one of the
most terrifying demonstrations i had
ever conceived
scarcely had i crossed the sill when
there descended upon the whole company a
sudden and unheralded fear of hideous
intensity
distorting every face and evoking the
most horrible screams from nearly every
throat
flight was universal and in the clamor
and panic
several fell in a swoon and were dragged
away by their madly fleeing companions
many covered their eyes with their hands
and plunged blindly and awkwardly in
their race to escape
overturning furniture and stumbling
against the walls
before they managed to reach one of the
many doors
the cries were shocking and as i stood
in the brilliant apartment
alone and dazed listening to their
vanishing echoes
i trembled at the thought of what might
be lurking near me unseen
at a casual inspection the room seemed
deserted
but when i moved towards one of the
alcoves i thought i detected a presence
there
a hint of motion beyond the golden arch
doorway leading to another and somewhat
similar room
as i approached the arch i began to
perceive the presence more clearly
and then with the first and last sound i
ever uttered
a ghastly ulation that revolted me
almost as poignantly as its noxious
cause i beheld in full frightful
vividness
the inconceivable indescribable and
unmentionable monstrosity
which had by its simple appearance
changed a merry company to a herd of
delirious fugitives
i cannot even hint what it was like for
it was a compound of all that is unclean
uncanny unwelcome abnormal and
detestable
it was the ghoulish shade of decay
antiquity and disillusion
the putrid dripping eidolon of
unwholesome revelation
the awful bearing of that which the
merciful earth should always hide
god knows it was not of this world or no
longer of this world
yet to my horror i saw in its eaten away
and bone-revealing outlines
a leering abhorrent travesty on the
human shape
and in its moldy disintegrating apparel
and unspeakable quality that chilled me
even more
i was almost paralyzed but not too much
so to make a feeble effort towards
flight
a backwards stumble which failed to
break the spell in which the nameless
voiceless monster held me
my eyes bewitched by the glassy orbs
which stared loathsomely into them
refused to close though they were
mercifully blurred
and showed the terrible object but
indistinctly after the first shock
i tried to raise my hand to shut out the
sight yet so stunned were my nerves that
my arm could not fully obey my will
the attempt however was enough to
disturb my balance
so that i had to stagger forward several
steps to avoid
falling as i did so i became suddenly
and agonizingly aware of the nearness
of the carrion thing whose hideous
hollow breathing i half fancied i could
hear
nearly mad i found myself yet able to
throw out a hand
to ward off the fetid apparition which
pressed so close
when in one cataclysmic second of cosmic
nightmarishness
and hellish accident my fingers touched
the rotting outstretched paw of the
monster beneath the golden arch
i did not shriek but all the fiendish
ghouls that ride the nightwind shrieked
for me
as in that same second there crashed
down upon my mind a single fleeting
avalanche of soul annihilating memory
i knew in that second all that had been
i remembered beyond the frightful castle
in the trees
and recognized the altered edifice in
which i now stood
i recognized most terrible of all the
unholy abomination that stood leering
before me
as i withdrew my sullied fingers from
its own but in the cosmos there is balm
as well as bitterness and that balm is
nepenthe
in the supreme horror of that second i
forgot what had horrified me
and the burst of black memory vanished
in a chaos of echoing
images in a dream i fled from that
haunted and accursed pile
and ran swiftly and silently in the
moonlight
when i returned to the churchyard place
of marble and went down the steps
i found the stone trap door immovable
but i was not sorry
for i had hated the antique castle in
the trees
now i ride with the mocking and friendly
ghouls on the nightwind
and play by day amongst the catacombs of
nephron kha
in the sealed and unknown valley of
haddoff by the nile
i know that light is not for me save
that of the moon over the rock tombs of
neb
nor any gaiety save the unnamed feasts
of natacrus beneath the great pyramid
yet in my new wildness and freedom i
almost welcome the bitterness of
alienage
for although nepenthe has calmed me i
know always that i am an outsider
a stranger in this century and among
those who are still men
this i have known ever since i stretched
out my fingers to the abomination within
that great gilded frame
stretched out my fingers and touched a
cold and unyielding surface
of polished glass
you